وقفتنا الاخباريه الاولى مع مراسلنا في
السعوديه عبد الرحمن العصيمي وعن ريان
برناوي ناسا تعلن موعد ارسال ريانه بناوي
كاول رائده فضاء عربيه برضو انا كثير
مبسوطه في محطه عالميه او علميه عفوا مهمه
علميه للمحطه الدوليه تفاصيل اكثر حول
الموضوع الان جودي عبد الرحمن يلا يا عبد
الرحمن صباح الخير صباح الخير عادل صباح
الخير راويه وعوده حميدا الى صباح العربيه
طبعا اختلف مع عادل واتفق معاه كراويه انا
سعيد جدا للنساء جدا جدا وعلى فكره يعادل
في دراسه لا هذا انا سعيد يقول ان النساء
يتحملن الالم اكثر من الرجال في المرات
طبعا فالمراه
اي مكان تضعها هي في المكان المناسب شكلك
خايف من شيء ما راح اجادلك
ما وراء الشاشه
طيب خبر خبر
ناسة عن برنامج تفضل نعم يلا جود نعم عادل
انا محضر خير وكاله ناسا طبعا الامريكيه
اعلنت عن موعد اطلاق مهمه اكسيوم ميشن تو
لمحطه الفضاء الدوليه التي ستكون على
متنها اول رائده فضاء سعوديه ريانه برناوي
المهمه ستنطلق في 21 مايو المقبل فيما
ستحمل المركبه ايضا رفقه برناوي مواطنها
رائد الفضاء علي القرني وسيلتقيان برائد
الفضاء الاماراتي سلطان النيابي الموجود
اساسا وحاليا في محطه في المحطه الدوليه
الهيئه السعوديه عادل للفضاء وراويه كانت
كشفت
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات